Brian: It's Brian Lehrer Live.
For decades futurists have been
predicting that education would be
revolutionized by
computers and the internet.
First we heard lots about
putting libraries online then
computers in the classroom.
Then universities like MIT
offering free courseware,
but nobody figured on a
young man named Salman Khan.
His site teaches math, science, history
and more to hundreds of thousands
worldwide and it's all free.
Salman: The Khan Academy is most known for
what's now about 1000 videos on Youtube.
It starts literally at 1 + 1
= 2 and it goes all the way
up to college level calculus and physics.
Everything is in these very short
encapsulated videos one concept at a time.
My cousin Nadia was visiting me from
New Orleans when I was in Boston
and she was having trouble with math.
She was in sixth grade at the time.
I agreed to do this
remote tutoring with her.
So I started putting up videos
on Youtube, and before I knew it
random people all over the world
started watching them and sending
me letters and testimonials and I
started getting excited about it
and I just kept going.
Man black jacket: I think I've learned
more about math in the past three weeks
than I had in all four years
of my high school studies.
Man red hat: When you watch them
you just comprehend everything.
You just get it.
Man black shirt: I ended up passing a
whole bunch of tests from his videos.
Salman: One thing that kind of shocked me,
I get a lot of letters
from the Middle East.
I get a lot of letters from
Latin America, Ethiopia, Uganda.
It's really reached far more students
than I could have ever imagined.
Right now there are about 1000 videos.
I started recording them
about three years ago.
Now I'm doing it full-time.
I'm hoping to be able to put out
a couple of hundred videos a year.
I see a world where literally anyone with
access to a computer and the internet
will be able to go to the Khan Academy
and get a world class education.
Brian: Impressive right?
So, let's get to know the man behind
this virtual global classroom.
Joining us live via Skype
from Mountain View California,
Khan Academy founder, Salman Khan.
Hey Salman. Hello from New York.
Thanks for doing this with us.
Salman: Hi Brian. Good to be here.
Brian: I gather you believe you're a
better teacher on video than in person.
Is that correct?
Salman: That's what my cousins
first told me when I put up
the very first Youtube video.
I viewed it as a bit of
a backhanded compliment.
I was doing these remote tutoring
sessions, these virtual sessions with them
and I think what they liked
about the Youtube version
of me as opposed to the live
version of me is that they
didn't have the stress of feeling
like their cousin in Boston
was judging them or that they had
to answer questions immediately
or fear feeling or looking
stupid to the instructor and
that they could watch and pause
and repeat whatever they wanted to.
Brian: 1500 videos, 14-million views.
What's the genesis of this Salman?
Salman: Just like I just said, it started
with me tutoring my cousins remotely.
They were in New Orleans, I was in Boston
and it worked out really well for them
when I had one or two or
three that I was tutoring.
They started doing well so I
wanted to tutor more and more.
I had a day job.
I was an analyst at a hedge fund at the
time and the logistics got difficult
and I thought well it at least would
be nice, maybe I could scale myself up
a little bit if I made some Youtube
videos and as you just mentioned,
their initial feedback, I thought
it would be nice to have suppliment
something they could
use to review concepts.
It wouldn't be as good as our live
interactions, but the first feedback
I heard from them was that
it was actually better.
Brian: Let's see an
example of you teaching.
This in particular is you teaching,
of all things, differential equations.
Salman: And what's interesting here and
how this is a departure from what we've
learned before about regular equations.
Let me write down a regular equation
just to remind you what they look like.
So a regular equation if we had one
variable would look something like this.
I don't know, X squared plus the cosine
of X is equal to the square root of X.
I just made that up.
Here the solution is a number or
sometimes it's a set of numbers.
Sometimes there's more than one right?
If you have a polynomial you
could have more than one value
of X that satisfy this equation.
Here for a differential equation,
the solution is a function.
Our goal is to figure out what function
of X, and here I wrote F of X explicitly
but what function of X
explicitly satisfies this
relationship or this equation.
So let me show you what I mean by that.
I have my differential equations book from
college so I'm going to use that as we go.
Brian: Ah, that high school
math feeling. There it is.
Salman: (laughing) That was
well beyond high school math.
Brian: I guess.
How do you approach - I mean okay you
came out of hedge funds, whatever.
Were you an expert in
differential equations?
Salman: An expert is kind of a loaded word
especially when you think about things
in academic topics.
I'm not a cutting edge researcher at the
leading edge of differential equations.
I have not contributed to the
field of differential equations.
But I am someone who loved math.
I was into math in high school, college.
I was a math major, but I teach things
outside of my credentialed areas as well.
The way I see it is as
long as someone has -
I think what I bring to the table is
being able to connect the intuition behind
a lot of concepts and be able to
communicate it in a way that I wish it was
delivered to me the first time.
That's really what I'm trying to do.
Brian: And you do all of these yourself?
All 1500 videos in every subject is you.
Salman: It's all me.
I joke I'm the faculty
of the Khan Academy.
Brian: Are there subjects that
are harder for you to do well?
Salman: You know, I like challenging
myself because when I started doing this
a lot of people said okay you've done
some algebra, can you do calculus?
Once you do calculus can you do chemistry?
And once you do chemistry
can you do the humanities.
I always like pushing the
boundaries and I just naturally
like learning different topics.
I wouldn't say harder is the word
but it requires more prep on my part
to do something like the French
Revolution than it does to do say the
differential equations videos.
Brian: Do you have a business model?
You give these away for free right?
Salman: Yeah. The decision was
made actually before I even quit
my job to make this a not for profit
entity, make sure it stays focused
on its goal which is to give
education away for free.
The way I'm paying my bills -
I was living off savings when I
quit my job in September in 2009,
and until recently I was
essentially just living off savings,
but very recently we've gotten enough
donations to support a small salary for me
and give us a bit of our own way
and hopefully we'll get more.
Brian: Is the paid university
concept an old fashioned concept
as far as your concerned?
Or is this just an alternative
for a very select group of people?
Salman: Well it's
definitely an alternative.
I don't think it's an alternative
for a select group of people.
When you look at the user base
there's people who are gifted students
who want to race ahead.
There's a lot of college students
at all different skill levels.
There are homeschoolers using it.
There are retirees using it.
So I wouldn't say it's selective.
It's a fairly broad audience.
And it's at minimum that.
It's at minimum kind of nice to have.
In terms of the college experience
I think there are things the
colleges are doing right.
I think its nice to go to a campus
that's well manicured and have
a nice experience there, but I
think this does challenge some of
the notions of why do we have these
300-person lectures at some university.
Actually, at all universities you
have these 300-person lectures
when you can get on demand
instruction at your own pace,
when you want it.
You don't have to take notes.
It's always there for you.
Brian: Who are your users primarily?
I realize it's a diverse group, but
do you find certain kinds of people,
certain groups of people are
really hitting on your stuff
for certain uses in their lives?
Salman: Yeah, I mean the core
users are who you would expect.
It's I would say high school and
college students, mainly in the US,
mainly North America.
I'd say about 80% North America,
20% the rest of the world.
Brian: For what? As kind of an online
Sparknotes or some other reason?
Salman: Yeah, I think they're students
who are stuck in a math class,
either they missed some days, they
zoned out through a couple of lectures
or they don't connect with the
professor they have and they use this
either as a supplement or to catch
up or really as their primary source
of understanding the concepts.
I get a lot of letters from people
who don't use a textbook anymore
to learn the concepts, a few people
who don't show up at lecture anymore.
Brian: But go ahead.
That's one core group.
Salman: And the others, you
know the homeschoolers love it.
I didn't think about it at first,
but it's kind of an obvious group
that would appreciate this type of
thing both for the students directly
and for the teachers and for the parents.
I've actually gotten -
Some groups are using it for teacher
training, which is a compliment.
It is actually being
used in the classroom.
I get letters from teachers who are
one assigning the lectures for homework
instead of reading, and some teachers
are showing it in the classroom
and then using that as a
starting point for discussion.
Brian: And you're obviously very
organized about how you do this.
We're going to show another video,
a little bit of you talking about
how some of the math and
science videos are organized.
Salman: Sure.
And then when you think about
the sciences, we have physics
and the physics playlist is mainly
I call applied algebra problems.
So, you might want to watch physics
right around after you finish algebra.
There's only a few videos
that require calculus.
I'll eventually make an entire
playlist on calculus-based physics.
Most of this is just is just algebra-based
physics so you're ready to go if you
have a good solid
understanding of algebra.
And then the other sciences, the
chemistry it'd be nice to have algebra
out of the way prealgebra is
probably enough for most of it.
Prealgebra is probably enough
for most of it, but if you have
your algebra out of the way
then you're going to have no trouble
at all with the chemistry playlist.
Then biology does deal with a little
bit of probability and things like that.
So, it wouldn't hurt but that's actually,
that doesn't even require too much
mathematics or at least the mathematics
that I've diagramed here.
We could put biology here.
I guess the big takeaway is that algebra
is really important for pretty much
anything you want to do.
There are some genetics
problems that require some
basic level and some population
genetics problems that
have some biology in it.
And then all the finance
and economics that also, I
think, it assumes a base level
of algebraic understanding.
So the things on banking.
Brian: So, that's, as I said
very organized, and I guess
that's the same kind of
thing that any university
would do as they're figuring out
what's a prerequisite for what.
Right?
Salman: Right. That's the general idea,
and actually this video was a biproduct
of there's so much content on the site now
that I got a lot of requests from people
who just were kind of lost,
what do I view after what?
And the one area where I think this
diverges from the university model -
The university model is very -
I mean that diagram was kind of class
based but I think what's here is a lot
more granular so you can
kind of go straight to the
concept based prerequisites
as opposed to an entire class.
Brian: Are you interested in trying to
get accredited or is that not a goal?
Salman: It's a long-term goal maybe to
have some type of direct accreditation.
I mean I can imagine a world where
actually have a software piece
where we give people exercises
and things like that, and you know
at the end of the day, ten years in
the future it might be a lot more
informative to an employer or university
as opposed to saying you have a 3.9 GPA
to actually give someone the data
of all of the work that you've done.
But in the short-term, maybe
the next year or two, I do see
a reality where we can tell
people, "Look if you've understood
all of these concepts you are ready to
go take the GED and you're likely to pass
it, or if you take the SAT because of the
exercises you've done we have
this level of confidence that
you will get a X on the SAT."
So we can view the Khan Academy
is kind of your coach and then you
get your external credential
from some other source.
Brian: I didn't see you in any
of the videos that we screened.
Do your students ever see you at a smart
board or with an overhead projector
or anything like that in these videos?
Salman: No, and you know the form
factor started off out of me just
not having a video camera, but
then I got a lot of feedback
that this form factor actually works
for a lot of people even though now
I probably could get a video
camera and go at a whiteboard,
but people say that it
feels a lot more intimate.
The instructor's face isn't a distraction.
It's kind of like they
feel like I'm the voice.
I'm either sitting next to them
and tutoring them or they feel like
I'm actually inside of
their brain talking to them.
So I think I'll just stick with that.
It's actually funny because I've
gotten letters from people who imagine
me in completely different ways than
I might be and they kind of project
their own impressions onto
me which is kind of a neat
artifact of this form factor.
Brian: You said that one of your goals
is to teach the way you always wanted
to be taught.
Can you put that into words?
Salman: Yeah, you know I think it's -
I'm finding this out more and more
the more concepts I do that there's
a lot of intuitive connections between
a lot of subjects but I think the
1000 page text books and then you
know to some degree the beaurocracies
of the standards making organizations.
They kind of chop them up to a level
that you lose all of the intuition.
You lose all of the cross
subject interactions and for me,
what made math fun, what made
science fun was to really explore
things and see how different
concepts were connected and what
a formula is actually
saying about the universe.
I think people who watch the Khan
Academy they really find I'm not just
throwing formulas at you.
I give you an intuition for what the
formula is saying, and I also tell you
what it's saying about the universe
generally, what are its implications,
and also how did we get that formula.
I don't just say memorize it and apply
it, and I think when you start learning
that way, one it's a lot more fun
because we all actually do want
to learn about the universe and it
actually builds a really, really strong
foundation when you learn
more advanced topics.
Brian: Which are your most popular videos?
Salman: Introduction to trigonometry is -
Brian: Really?
Saman: That or probably
introduction to calculus.
Those are probably the
two most popular videos.
Brian: Why?
Salman: Well, I think both people
take those courses, both people are at
the same time kind of
intimidated by those courses.
I think when you watch
those first two videos -
The introduction to calculus is an
interesting one because I've had
letters from people who've taken
calculus and who got As in calculus
and then they watch that video and
they say, "Oh, I finally understand
what calculus is about,
what's it even good for."
So there's that, and I think introduction
to trigonometry is a huge pain point
for a lot of students and so
a lot of them kind of end up
on Youtube looking for help.
Brian: So, what's the future for you?
Is it collaboration with others like
you, if there are any others like you
to continue to grow or something else?
Salman: You know I'm very open
to it, and when I started off
when I only had 100 videos
I thought that was the road I would
take, that I would find a team of other
people like me and we would
just collectively do it.
I'm open to it but I've
kind of committed myself.
I enjoy doing it.
I've done 1500 videos over four
years and most of those four years
I was working a day job.
I've done about 600 since
I quit my job in September.
So I'm fairly confident that I
could tackle a big chunk of it,
but I'm sure other people will join in.
But then augment it with software
and kind of a community built
around the 200,000 people
using the site right now.
To really turn it into a virtual school.
Brian: Hey Salman, great
stuff. Thanks for coming on.
Salman: Great. Thank you.